c'était quelqu'un qui arrivait dans la
musique classique i bouleverser tout
véritablement
[Musique]
grand compositeur français claude
debussy est né dans cette maison le 22
août 1862 ici ses parents tenaient une
boutique de faïence au rez-de-chaussée
et logeal étages situé à saint germain
en laye la maison ferme ses portes au
public le 31 octobre pour deux ans pour
cette maison ancienne du xviie siècle
les travaux se sont imposés de même on
voit qu'il ya des infiltrations d'eau on
voit que tout se dégrade petit à petit
et il ya également la question de
l'accessibilité au public la maison
aujourd'hui n'est pas accessible aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
l'escalier du xviie siècle est le seul
accès aujourd'hui dans les étages
objectif des travaux redonner à la passe
est son aspect historique implanter un
ascenseur et revoir la muséographie la
muséographie et sera véritablement revu
de fond en comble avec les outils qu'on
a aujourd'hui c'est à dire les outils
multimédias qui seront également
présents quelque chose qu'on n'a pas
aujourd'hui mais avec l' écoute musicale
beaucoup plus présente
clair de lune verrerie prélude claude
debussy est considéré aujourd'hui comme
le précurseur de la musique classique
actuel un personnage qui a amené quelque
chose de profondément nouveau en fait
sans debussy la musique classique
n'aurait pas connu ce ce changement
c'est vraiment debussy qui fait rentrer
la musique classique dans le xxème
siècle la réouverture est prévue courant
2023 une fois la maison fermée au public
le lieu continuera de vivre avec une
saison musicale hors les murs des
concerts prévus au conservatoire au
musée maurice denis ou encore à l'hôtel
de ville
[Musique]